we're told a company produces processing
chips for cell phones at one of its
large factories two percent of the chips
produced are defective in some way
a quality check involves randomly
selecting and testing 500 chips what are
the mean and standard deviation of the
number of defective processing chips in
these samples so like always try to
pause this video and have a go at it on
your own and then we will work through
it together all right
so let me define a random variable that
we're going to find the mean and
standard deviation of and i'm going to
make that random variable the number of
defective processing chips in a 500 chip
sample
so let's let x
be equal to the number
of
defective
chips
in
500
chip
sample
so the first thing to recognize is that
this will be a binomial variable
this is
binomial
how do we know its binomial well it's
made up of 500 it's a finite number of
trials right over here the probability
of getting a defective chip you could do
this as a probability of success it's a
little bit counterintuitive that a
defective chip would be a success but
we're summing up the defective chips so
we would view the probability of a
defect or i should say defective
chip
it is constant across these 500 trials
and we will assume that they are
independent of each other 0.02
you might be saying hey well are we
replacing the chips before or after but
we're assuming it's from a functionally
infinite population or if you want to
make it feel better you could say well
maybe you are replacing the chips
they're not really telling us that right
over here so we'll assume that each of
these trials are independent of each
other and that the probability of
getting a defective chip stays constant
here and so this is a binomial random
variable or binomial variable and we
know the formulas for the mean and
standard deviation of a binomial
variable so the mean
the mean of x which is the same thing as
the expected value of x is going to be
equal to
the number of trials n
times the probability of a success on
each trial
times p
so what is this going to be
well this is going to be equal to we
have 500
trials and then the probability of
success on each of these trials is
0.02 so it's 500 times
0.02 and what is this going to be 500
times 2 hundredths is going to be
it's going to be equal to 10.
so that is your expected value of the
number of defective processing chips or
the mean
now what about the standard deviation
so
the standard deviation
of our random variable x
well that's just going to be equal to
the square root of the variance of
our random variable x
so i could just write it i'm just
writing it all the different ways that
you might see it because sometimes the
notation is the most confusing part in
statistics
and so this is going to be the square
root of what
well the variance of a binomial variable
is going to be equal to the number of
trials
times
the probability of success in each trial
times one minus the probability of
success in each trial and so in this
context this is going to be equal to
you're going to have the 500
500 times
0.02 0.02
times 1 minus 0.02 is 0.98
so times
0.98 and all of this is under the
radical sign i didn't make that radical
sign
long enough and so what is this going to
be
well let's see 500 times 0.02 we already
said that this is going to be 10 10
times 0.98 this is going to be equal to
the square root of
9.8 so it's going to be
i don't know three point something if we
want we can get a calculator out to feel
a little bit better about this value
so
i'm going to take
9.8 and then take the square root of it
and i get 3.5 round to the nearest
hundredth 3.13 so this is approximately
3.13 for the standard deviation if i
wanted the variance it would be 9.8
but they ask for the standard deviation
so that's why we got that all right
hopefully you enjoyed that